Using Postman and Curl were great
tools for building our http requests.
But let's create these requests and
responses in Python so
that we can embed those functionalities
into our server-side code.
Let's start by writing a simple
Python application that does
the geolocation API requests for us.
I'm going to name this
Python program geocode.py.
I will import the httplib2 and
json libraries into my program.
Httplib2 is a comprehensive
http client library in Python.
And the JSON library in Python is for
converting in-memory Python objects
to a serialized JSON representation.
Now, I will create a function and
call it getGeocodeLocation.
It will take in an input string,
that is the name for
the place we want to get
the coordinates for.
Then, I create a variable for
storing my google_api_key.
You should paste in your key here.
Having your secret keys
visible in your Python code
isn't the safest practice for live code.
But it's fine for this activity.
Now, in my input string, I need to
replace any spaces with plus signs, such
that there are no breaks in my URL path,
and the server can read it correctly.
I do that with
the replace function here.
I then build the URL here and
pass in the location string and
my Google API key.
Next, I create an instance of
the http class and name it h.
I can now create a GET request
with the request method here.
This request will return an array with
two values, the http response and
the content.
I will call json.loads on the content
to format it in a way that is easier to
read, but still in proper JSON format.
Now, just so we can see what
the response header looks like,
I will have it print to the terminal.
And then I will return the result
variable which contains the formatted
content that I requested.
Now, I will save my code and
start a Python instance in the terminal,
in the same directory where
my geocode.py file is.
I import the getGeocodeLocation
method from the geocode file, and
we're trying to get the location
of my hometown, Dallas, Texas.
Here, we can see that our response
header contains a successful status code
along with a lot of other meta data
that Google provided with our request.
Looking at the actual
content of the response,
we see that we got a lot more data than
just latitude and longitude coordinates.
But nevertheless, the information we
requested is in the response somewhere.
In this next video, let's see if we can
figure out a way to parse through all of
this information in this response.